demain sur france 2 les amateurs de
sport seront comblés avec la
retransmission en direct de la finale de
la coupe d'afrique des nations à 18h10
bien sûr de football
elle opposera le nigeria à la zambie le
favori à une équipe ressuscité dominique
leglou demain au moment où retentit
khalil me sens bien
les dirigeants de l'équipe nationale
pourront vraiment prétendre qu'il croit
au miracle
souvenez vous c'était presque il y un an
jour pour jour le 27 avril 1993 l'équipe
de football de zambie été victime d'un
tragique accident d'avion à de
libreville au gabon
trente victimes dont 18 joueurs pendant
une semaine le pays gros dit voulait
renoncer aux qualifications pour la
coupe du monde de football et puis en
mémoire des disparus
les zambiens ont décidé de rebâtir une
équipe autour des deux survivants de
joueurs qui évoluent à l'étranger
n'était pas de ce tragique voyage
kalusha bwalya johnson voyant même un
moment fait espérer que la zambie à
l'étalé aux états unis
hélas le maroc ou le dernier mot
fabuleuse renaissance c'est là dans
cette région du nord du pays le
copperbelt on alla chercher les nouveaux
talents le copperbelt la ceinture de
cuivre du pays fournit 80% des joueurs
de la nouvelle équipe mufulira et le
village d'origine de kalusha bwalya la
grande star du psv eindhoven et si le
plus jeune de ses frères n'est pas
encore en équipe nationale jo le cadet
l'a rejoint pour défendre les couleurs
des aigles aidés par les fédérations
étrangères près d'entraîneur stage à
tarif préférentiel équipements sportifs
la zambie et le type de coeur de cette
19ème coupe d'afrique des nations
mais en finale face aux professionnels
mercenaires nigérian le petit poucet
zambien devra croire une deuxième fois
au miracle sait-on jamais après tout
s'il parvient à museler l'appétit d'ogre
de rashidi yekini le buteur nigérian
5 but dans cette coupe d'afrique tout
est possible il suffit juste du poids de
ma 18h sur france 2